ja eigentlich ist es etwas das mich
schon bewegt hat als das sondierungs
papier von der ampelkoalition die er
künftig entstehen soll herauskommen klar
wir haben erwartet da wird das wahlalter
ab 16 drin stehen aber nur wenige tage
ich glaube es war zwei tage vorher
gingen diese aufträge durch den medien
eine grüne die neue sprecherin der
grünen jugend rechtfertigt er sich für
tweets diese mit 15 abgesetzt hatte mit
na ja man ist da noch nicht reif und
noch nicht so zurechnungsfähig dass man
da überhaupt sinnige tweets absetzen
kann ja aber mit 16 ist man jetzt reif
genug um zu bestimmen wer unser land
regiert und den nächsten höhepunkt den
lieferte wahnsinn oder kann sie in kirk
ist tut mir leid dass ich den namen
nicht wirklich weiß aber sie hat aber
ganz besagt und wir werden auch sicher
noch mal darauf zu sprechen kommen das
ist ein skandal ist dass 25 prozent der
erstwähler die fdp gewählt haben
das ist weller bashing vom feinsten und
undemokratische noch dazu gerade wenn
man sich anschaut dass diese partei nun
in eine koalition miteinander geben
wollen ich bin der überzeugung dass wir
ein problem an den schulen bisher haben
bevor wir das wahlalter absenken und das
problem lautet dass wir nicht früh genug
mit politischer bildung anfangen mit 16
habe ich mich sicherlich lieber sogar
mit meinen freunden und vielleicht auch
ein gutes bier getroffen als politik zu
machen aber vielleicht schaffen wir es
durch frühe bildung für politische
bildung das aufzuheben deswegen setze
ich mich dafür ein dass wir in jeder
schule in ganz deutschland ab der
siebten klasse politischen unterricht
machen erst wenn wir die
grundvoraussetzungen geschaffen haben
dass jeder schüler weiß was er denn dort
eigentlich fehlt und wen er wählt dann
können wir das wahlalter absenken niebel
ich kann nicht etwas beruhigen ich komme
aus einem land wo es das wahlalter 16
jahren gibt und der staat steht noch
immer meistens jedenfalls aber ich
glaube nur mit dem fach politische
bildung ist es nicht getan es ist zu
einfach sicher ich hatte in der schule
zum beispiel ich habe haben bei opfer im
speziellen gymnasium mit
wirtschaftsforscher und sagen woher du
kommst aus österreich ist
man hört vielleicht
und auf diesem gymnasium hat sich neben
deutsch mathe physik geschichte auch
volkswirtschaft betriebswirtschaft
bürgerliches recht politische bildung
und ich glaube
es braucht mehr aus nur politische
bildung auch wie sieht unser
steuersystem aus was geht eigentlich von
meinem lohn berg und so weiter das habe
ich alles in der schule gelernt wie
setzt sich unser bruttoinlandsprodukt
zusammen wie funktioniert der staat im
grunde genommen aber auch bürgerliches
recht wie schon verträge aus ich meine
das erste was die kinder machen wenn sie
aus der schule kommen die wollen dann
irgendwann einmal ausziehen die müssen
mietvertrag unterschreiben die
schließen sich online geschäften wie wie
sieht es da mit der vertraglichen
situation aus das habe ich alles in der
schule gelernt und ich glaube das ist
deutlich wichtiger für politische
bildung in dem sinne als wie
funktioniert jetzt rein demokratisch
unser staat aber es trägt er dazu bei
wie funktioniert der staat gerade so was
zu verstehen wir setzt sich das
bruttoinlandsprodukt zu sagen du hast
aber völlig recht das ist ein beispiel
die politische bildung aber es tut
natürlich mehr dazu und dazu gehört auch
jugendbeteiligung stadt scheint
demokratie für jugendliche da gibt es so
viel zu tun finde ich gerade was das
angeht ja also ich sehe die größte
gefahr die ich sehe bei den bayern mit
16 eigentlich in der
umweltschutzbewegung also wenn wir uns
mal beides verfügt schaden gucken oder
ende gelände die grüne jugend dass die
teilweise fordern was für ein
antikapitalistisches bild sie haben und
was für verbindungen zu linksextremisten
gehören das ist ja ganz deutlich also
wenn man diese starke bewegung hat die
eigentlich null ahnung von wirtschaft
hat und da stimme ich dir zu das problem
liegt an den schulen dass man den
kindern weit denkt wenigstens grundlagen
von marktwirtschaft oder wirtschaft
funktionierten staat er muss gut
wirtschaftende mit für uns ist alles
leisten kann aber nein die jungen wollen
ja eine strahlend systemwechsel also
wenn sie sich auch mal die bücher
angucken von den zwei
aktivistinnen die bekanntesten carola
rakete und luisa neubauer da stehen ja
sachen drin da stellen sich mir die
haare also und diese bewegung
beeinflusst eben die jugend und wenn man
sollte da die kahle hat die gerade hier
auf dem vormarsch sind da sehe ich das
schon exotisch wenn man das alter
absenkt also als ich 16 jahre alt war da
habe ich mich für politik interessiert
und ich wusste mit 16 schon was ich
später werden wählen werde und ich kann
mich an meine schulzeit gerade in der
zeit noch erinnern dass wir uns
parlamentsdebatten angeschaut haben und
wir ja eigentlich auch sehr gut
informiert waren und
wir reden hier von und gerade in
deutschland von 1 5 millionen wähler
also in der gruppe in einem intervall 16
bis 18 und viele themen worüber die
politik heute diskutiert und entscheidet
das sind themen die diese generation
oder von denen diese menschen später
betroffen sind wenn wir heute über
klimaschutz reden wenn wir heute über
digitalisierung reden wenn wir über
renten reden auch wenn wir über finanzen
reden das sind alles themen wo ich sage
die künftige generation ist davon
betroffen und selbstverständlich ist es
aus meiner sicht sinnvoll wenn diese
jungen menschen auch sehr früh die
möglichkeit haben sich daran zu
beteiligen es gibt ja auf kommunaler
ebene aus als vielen jahren diese
diskussionen aktives wahlrecht passives
wahlrecht aber ich habe häufig die
beobachtung gemacht dass gerade junge
menschen wenn sie wussten sie dürfen
bald wählen dass sie dann besonders
interessiert waren besonders aufmerksam
waren und sensibel waren für politische
themen ich glaube grundsätzlich ist es
gut für eine demokratie wenn junge
menschen früh informiert sind junge
menschen früh eingebunden sind also
politische partizipation ist ein ist
eine außerordentlich wichtige sache und
macht uns letztendlich auch als
demokratie stark und
unbedingt anfügen der mir auch wirklich
angst um dass man ab 16 machten das ist
leider meinen bundesland thüringen wenn
ich mir dort die juniorwahl angucke und
wer dort gewinnt wird mir angst und
bange und ich glaube auch und das ist ja
nicht viel besser wenn die leute älter
werden in thüringen sondern wie viele
genau das kann sich also tatsächlich ist
der unterschied doch noch mal deutlich
besondere unterschied ist tatsächlich
noch mal deutlich anders gerade auch
einmal auf die landtagswahlergebnisse
und ich sage ich könnte ich will dass
nur die zudem ihr den kram passt
lassen sie mich kurz punkt zu ende
führen ich mir mache dass angst und
bange und ich glaube auch dass dafür
eben ein problem ist dass wir eine
schlechte politische bildung in diesem
land haben eine wochenstunde in klasse 9
und 10 da lerne ich gerade mal wie um
mir die verfasstheit des staates ist und
wer die verfassung überhaupt gegeben hat
das geht nicht meines erachtens und ich
glaube wenn du den schülern ordentlich
erklärt was ihr denn eigentlich wollten
die radikalen dort an von rechts und
links dann glaube ich auch wirklich dass
bei etwas verändern können ja die
radikalen in thüringen sind ja schon
eine tragende partei also zumindest
fragen sich vielleicht nicht den staat
selbst ein bisschen wahlergebnisse die
nahe an die mehrheiten kommen das sehen
wir in sachsen ja auch ich kann mir
durchaus vorstellen dass die partei auch
nennen wir sie ruhig beim namen die afd
natürlich auch mit ihren mitgliedern
irgendwann schulen wenn es nicht schon
tut und auch lehrerstellen und
dergleichen bevölkert das ist der
normale gang der dinge so und ich frage
mich nur wenn man so viel wert legt auf
die schulische bildung wer schützt mich
denn davor dass lehrer eine bestimmte
ideologie oder eine bestimmte art und
weise der ausrichtung den schülern
verfärben verbreiten gegenüber schülern
verbreiten
wenn die einzige die einzige quelle für
die schüler dann eben weil die lehrkraft
ist ich halte von 16 gar nichts muss ich
sagen weil ich finde es gibt eine
bestimmte reife die auch bei
bundestagswahlen geld muss den natürlich
sind 16 jährige interessiert wenn sie
beides 14 mal gucken wir damit geht da
sind auch 14 jährige zwölfjährige dabei
mit dem gleichen anspruch natürlich
interessiert in dem zustand der welt
auch zwölfjährige dann könnte man auch
sagen dass doch zwölfjährige wählen weil
es gibt sie genauso an die themen
digitalisierung und nein es braucht ein
bestimmtes alter der reifen und das ist
18 für bundestagswahlen davon bin ich
fest gehört sein aber ich verlange ich
finde das argument so ein bisschen dünn
wenn wir einfach sagen wir wollen wenig
mit 16 wählen lassen weil wir angst
davor haben was sie wählen also sowohl
hier im beispiel thüringen oder auch bei
file is for future es gibt genug von
freies computer ist schon über 18 sind
im gegenteil spricht es nicht eigentlich
dafür dass man sagt eigentlich
repräsentiert die politik die themen der
jungen überhaupt so stark warum sind sie
denn auf der straße ja also ich glaube
das problem ist wirklich die schule also
ich habe meine schulbuchverlag
gearbeitet
und ich habe mich mit schulbüchern
beschäftigt geguckt wie wird er
diskutieren gelernt im deutschunterricht
und es ist schon sehr links also der
schüler betrieb die pädagogik ist sehr
links beeinflusst und so lange man
ebenso ein sehr antikapitalistisches
bild hat und nicht ausgewogen ja und
nicht ausgewogen zum beispiel über das
wirtschaftliche system unterrichtet wird
sei dank finde ich problematisch deutete
jugendwehr weil sie so sehr unter dem
aber wenn es zu links ist höre ich das
ist so rechts fernseher sind
grundproblem von thüringen ich bin nur
einen punkt noch den ich gerne
hinzugefügt hätte noch hinzu findet der
weitere ist nämlich kommunalrecht das
kommunale wahlrecht ab 16 bei uns auch
verschwindend geringer teil der da
überhaupt zur wahl geht von den 16 bis
18 bei der kommunalwahl grundsätzlich
ist bei der bundestagswahl und
landtagswahl sind die statistiken ich
kenne die zahlen natürlich auch die
wahlbeteiligung für kommunalwahlen dass
wir aber wissen dass der teil der
jugendlichen sehr viel weiter also man
kann das ja noch mal aufspalten nach den
altersgruppen wie da die wahlbeteiligung
waren da sehen wir dass sie deutlich
unter schnitt ist übrigen auch zur
bundestagswahl gewesen nicht deutlich
unter schnitt aber unter schnitt aber
das ist doch eigentlich auch kein
schlechtes zeichen wenn es eigentlich
wählen gehen ich finde sind ganz
schlecht aber
kam es nicht auch ein signal dafür sein
dass er tendenziell die zur wahl gehen
die sich so genug informiert fühlen dass
sie wirklich sagen ich will eine stimme
abgeben und dass die anderen die soeben
hatten ein solches leben oft falsche
ansatz unser ansatz muss sagen dass
jeder einzelne von denen informiert
genug ist um möglicherweise ändern
entscheidung treffen zu können nicht
dass sich jeder danach entscheide aber
nicht jetzt informiert genug oder nicht
sondern jeder muss so gut informiert
sein dass er möglicherweise wählen gehen
kann was ich sehr spannend finden
seither sebastian ist dass du gesagt
hast du hat es auch wirtschaft dieser
schule und und so weiß man das kommt
wirklich zu preußen das thema wirtschaft
würde man vielleicht dann auch schaffen
da die diese fronten aufzubrechen das
müsste eigentlich viel stärker in den
fokus gerückt werden menschen
beschäftigt das im grunde ihr leben lang
und wenn auch indirekt vielleicht und es
müsste viel wirtschaft muss ein
pflichtfach werden